this is a production of cornell
university
okay hello everyone i'm jacob chose i
work in larry's smart slab in
cornell agritech up in geneva today i'll
be talking about accumulation of
cannabinoids under various stresses and
high cbd hemp
uh presenting some results from what
we've been calling the 2019
hemp stress trial so
hemp is a cannabis sativa plant with
less than 0.3
total thc and the major market for hemp
right now
is cannabidiol or cbd which is already a
billion dollar market
and is expected to grow exponentially
over the next few years
uh cbd is isolated from hemp
inflorescence
and it reaches its highest concentration
in mature unpollinated female brats
um one of the things that a lot of
people are concerned about when growing
hemp for cbd production
is the production of the psychoactive
tetrahydrocannabinol or thc
which is what distinguishes hemp from
marijuana
and there's an arbitrary threshold of
0.3 percent
uh so knowing what results in higher or
lower production of thc is going to be
very important
for growers who want to stay under that
limit and
if you look at sort of what's
popularized in the media or at least was
popular
when these articles were written it
appears that hemp stress is expected to
have
a significant effect on thc so if you
look at the
the hemp and the marijuana blogs uh for
instance here
for tuna hemp uh suggests that growers
need to be aware that plant stresses can
result in thc spikes
rx leaf suggests that uh any plant
stress can tip it over point three
uh cooperative extension says that the
main thing that causes thc spikes are
stressors
and the new york times mentions of the
chemistry of hemp
that can cause them to over produce thc
when stressed
uh so uh while a lot of people
uh think that hemp stress is going to be
very important
it made it all the way to the new york
times
there's very little evidence in the
literature that
links hemp stress and thc production
now part of that's because hemp has only
recently been
uh legalized for production in many
states
uh so what we wanted to do was look
explicitly and see if these sort of
popular sources have any truth to them
that hemp stress is going to
result in higher thc so just looking at
previous work going into this
we didn't expect that hemp stress would
have much
effect on spikes
uh in 2018 we found that there was a
fairly consistent ratio
among genetically similar plants we are
in a little bit of a natural experiment
as well
uh we grew two replicated fields one in
ithaca and one in geneva
and one of our fields was severely
flooded
and you can see here that plant is uh
pretty stressed
but we didn't see any effect on the cbd
dhc ratio
and we didn't see any thc spikes within
genetically similar plants
i know this isn't a perfect experiment
there could have been other factors at
play
and there may have even been some
selection bias as the plants that were
really stress
here uh just died so what we wanted to
do
was run a randomized complete block
design experiment to
see if stress affects the thc levels and
if stress affects this cbd to thc
ratio so to do this we had three
cultivars
in four reps with six total treatments
which i'll discuss in a minute
and we took shoot tip samples every week
for four weeks
and then um using hplc looked
at the cannabinoids that were produced
so we had six treatments we had our
control plants which were grown under
best practices under black plastic we
had powdery mildew which is a fungal
pathogen which we thought could induce a
response
rather surprisingly we're not 100 sure
on the evolutionary purpose of
cannabinoids it's been suggested that
they might be a factor in uh pest
response or pathogen response or maybe
even
uv response uh so we included powdery
mildew because we thought
it might induce more cannabinoids there
uh mechanical damage is something that
people are concerned about
it may hail there may be some wind
damage or
potential herbivory so we included that
as a potential stress
and to generate that stress we damaged
the plants for the grass trimmer
we had a flooding treatment with
saturated the soil regularly
and this was largely to repeat that 2018
finding in a controlled
experiment we also included two chemical
treatments
ethaphon which was found to increase
total cannabinoids
in a greenhouse study of marijuana and a
herbicide
at a low concentration to any light
herbicide drift
so that's what you see here these plants
have been sprayed with 0.5 percent
roundup
and they're pretty stressed
so this is just the control this is best
practices and this matches
a lot of the other data that we've been
seeing the cbd
increases over time and it's somewhat
cultivar dependent
uh so it started at week zero before
application of these
stresses all the cultivars are around
around three percent total cbd and then
at the end of the experiment
the cam or the cbd has either leveled
out in that one case
or is around 10 percent which is usually
where
growers aim to take the crop
so that's cbd and if we look at thc
the graph is actually very similar so if
you look at this total potential cbd and
this little inset
and the total potential cbd in this
larger
graph they look very similar very
similar ratio of cbd to thc over
time uh what's also very noteworthy
looking at this
is that these two cultivars the blue and
the red
they're significantly over that point
three percent thc
uh even under best practices as
unstressed as we could get them
so if the there's a very similar ratio
of cbd to thc
we'd expect that even without any
additional stresses or anything else
uh at around seven to eight percent cbd
we'd be getting non-compliant levels of
thc
and under some circumstances the crop
might have to be completely discarded
uh so that's in the control we wanted to
see if there was any effect
of any of these stresses on either the
ratio or the total amount of
cannabinoids
um and largely there was very
small effect of stress uh so if you look
at this total potential cbd
you can see that most of these
treatments cluster with the control
except for herbicide which is generally
a little lower and given how
stressed those plants are that's not all
together surprising the plants were
very significantly um
stressed they were they were fairly
close to death we had trouble finding
green tissue to
sample if you look at the total
potential thc
it's a very similar story it looks like
the ratios are about the same throughout
you see lower herbicide um and that's
we think largely because of uh just sort
of
general stress the plants are nearly
dead we also
did not see any huge spikes in thc
which is sometimes what has been
reported um
but when we look just at the harvest
time here and look at it statistically
we can see this total thc the only
significant
difference um compared to the control is
that the herbicide
has lower total thc so
it appears that stress does not cause
thc to spike
what's more if we look at this ratio of
total cbd over total thc
this ratio remains the same in all
comparisons
at harvest to explain why that happens
i'm going to talk a little bit about
the production of cannabinoids so
first off the first cannabinoid that
gets synthesized is
cvga and the amount of cbga that gets
synthesized is going to be a function
of a few things like trichome density
um production of this olaptonic acid
precursor
um activity of this got enzyme a whole
bunch of things like that
and a lot of these things apparently
have a strong genetic face is what we've
seen these stresses didn't affect them
too much
but can be slowed down by uh
nearly killing the plant with herbicide
so what happens in
hemp with cbd asymptotes is the cbga
gets converted to cdda which
can then be converted to cbd and in
marijuana
uh you have thca synthase which converts
to cbga to thca
which then gets converted to thc
so as i pointed out a few times these
hemp plants which
should only have this cbda synthase
produce a fairly consistent ratio of
cbda to thca
and as it turns out if you isolate that
cbda synthase or express it in a yeast
system
and incubate it with the cbga you get a
small amount of production
of this thc as well and what's uh
very encouraging is that the ratio that
you see in vitro is very similar to the
ratio that we see
in vivo so these hemp plants that were
growing that thca
is the result of promiscuous activity of
the cbda
synthase enzyme and none of these
stresses
apparently affect that promiscuous
activity
of the enzyme so
thc spikes are a real thing it's just a
lot of people have been attributing it
to stress
um while we could not see any uh spikes
due to stress
and um to summarize why we think that is
just in a few words is because those
plants
have active thca synthase enzyme in them
uh so cannabinoid type can be accurately
modeled by a single locus called the b
locus it comes in two major flavors the
bt
which has the active thca synthase and
the bd
which has active cbda synthase and since
hemp is diploid
you can get three chemotypes as they're
called bt dt
which produces mainly thc btbd
which produces significant amounts of
both and then chemotype 3
bdbd which is what you would think
most cbd hemp should be but
a lot of the commercially available
cultivars are not solely chemotype 3
a lot of them have significant numbers
of chemotype 2
and some even have some chemotype 1. so
here are
four different cultivars that we grew
this first one here that's all blue is
all chemotypes three
the next one has a little bit of
chemotype two
and this one in the bottom corner was in
fact two-thirds chemotype
two so unsurprisingly it produced a lot
of thc
now if you were just randomly sampling
you might
randomly pick a plant that's blue
chemotype 3
and then you know a week later you pick
one that's
orange chemotype 2 and blame it on the
stress
when in fact it was simply a genetic
phenomenon
it was just a different chemotype due to
a different gene at that b locus
so in summary stress has the potential
to alter cannabinoid content for
instance if you nearly kill the plant
with herbicide
cannabinoids will be lower but the
effect was generally fairly minor
very importantly the stress does not
affect the cbd to thc ratio at farthest
um and we think that the spikes that
people have been reporting
are likely due to sampling different
chemotypes as we're seeing that
chemotypes
uh segregation is very common in many
cultivars
another important result is that high
cbd plants are almost certain to test
above 0.3
thc when grown to a high cbd percentage
so what we've been advising growers to
do is to ensure that they're growing
seeds from a
reputable source that ideally don't have
any of that active thca synthase enzyme
and also to not get too greedy to test
and harvest before the plants get too
high
of level of cbd uh so that can remain
below
that threshold of thc
uh so for acknowledgements i'd like to
thank other members of the larry smart
lab particularly george stack and craig
carlson
i'd like to thank chris smartslav and
ali khala
for their work with powdery mildew and
the rose lab for working with
um the hplc to determine these
cannabinoids
uh this work was largely funded by new
york state department of ag and markets
and pixas international
and uh with that if i have any time left
i'd be happy to take some questions
great uh thank you for that um
really thorough talk jacob if anybody
has any questions they can
either unmute or put them in the chat
and make sure to fill out that feedback
form i put the link
in the chat as well
hey jacob this is this is travis
what is the amount of heat that's needed
to convert the
the precursor to cbd into cbd
right so cbda and thca
get converted into the active forms of
cbd and thc
and there's no if you look at the
decarboxylation profiles
they're temperature dependent so we've
had samples that have been left at room
temperature for a year
and they end up being mostly
decarboxylated
but one of the reasons why marijuana is
smoked is because high temperatures it
gets
decarboxylated very quickly so if
there's a
time temperature dependence and
they are different for different
cannabinoids this decarboxylation
and that's an area of active research
okay thanks
i think there's one more question in the
chat before we
move on uh faith asks have you
considered including mechanical stress
for another experiment so um
we were hoping that our uh mechanical
damaging the plant would sort of
encompass um any sort of major
mechanical stress
um it might be something different
um given that we saw very
clear no results i don't think we have
immediate plans
to um repeat work like this
uh we have a nice theory that it's just
that one enzyme
and we don't foresee it being affected
by
mechanical stress and we didn't see an
effect of our physical damage
so it would be another stress that could
potentially be included
but we uh don't really have any
immediate plans to test that
awesome uh thank you again jacob we can
all give him uh
the clap emojis um and i think ana's
gonna introduce our next speaker
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu